[Music]
with the somewhat surprised tweet on the
28th of February regarding a global
event happening this weekend and data
mind information and rumors stating that
will be having global events for every
weekend in March I thought that this
would be a good time to introduce a
super quick guide for those of you who
either haven't taken part in a global
event or don't fully understand what
they are
so what are global events
over a set period of time they offer new
mechanics that affect the global map and
mix up how you play the content based on
the different modifiers that each event
brings the examples coming up are based
on previous global events so it may vary
slightly for what we see going forward
but based on the fact that all
classified gear is now available in the
loop pool and that these are only
happening over a few days rather than a
week like in previous global events
it feels pretty safe to assume that
we're getting a repeat of the last ones
global event one outbreak this event is
all about keeping the enemy at range
global modifiers cannot be turned off
and will remain until the end of the
event the global modifier for global
event one is outbreak headshot kills
increase headshot damage for a duration
and hurt nearby enemies the group and
activity modifiers are optional
these can be activated on certain
activities for more challenge and
greater rewards in each event you'll see
these missions marked on the map so to
get the most out of this event
hit your headshots and keep some
distance between you the enemies and
your allies sniper and ranged builds
will be most effective in contrast to
global event one assault is all about
close-range combat the global modifier
is assault enemies are vulnerable and
all aged damage is increased at close
range the aim and thus event is to get
up close and personal with enemies but
also to keep in close proximity to your
fellow agents this will not only further
increase your damage but on the flipside
having some distance between you and
your allies will have NPCs doing more
damage so get cozy shotguns and Eastern
Jews will do well here
global event three strike strike is all
about explosions the global modifier is
enemies explode after they're killed
much like global event two you want to
keep some distance between you and your
allies as you can also trigger
explosions when sustaining too much
damage careful when getting too close to
an enemy explosions can lead to chain
reactions from nearby NPCs
self-sustainability and shield builds
make it through these modifiers quite
comfortably global event for ambush this
is all about standing still no seriously
don't move and you'll do a lot more
damage the global modifier is ambushed
agent deals increased damage when
stationary the aim here is to do as
little moving as possible at least well
in combat anyway utilize builds that do
better when you sit back like skill
power builds
so what's the big deal about global
events global events are currently the
easiest and fastest way to acquire
classified gear and each global event
has certain sets associated with it
for example outbreak has sets Lonestar
final measure and did I assault is
Stryker century and reclaimer strike has
predator defense banshee and nomad and
ambush has tactician alpha bridge fire
crest and hunters when playing through
the global event you're awarded with GE
credits these credits can be taken
through to the GE vendor to purchase GE
cashes these caches have a high chance
to drop between 1 and 3 classified
pieces based on the global event in
previous global events there were two
caches you could purchase standard and
superior when searching for classified
gear it's recommend that you buy the
more expensive superior GE cache for a
greater chance in the state of the game
they mentioned that there's likely to be
a bit of a change to the system we're
not sure when the suits be activated so
when it's known I'll place an update in
the description below on top of the
classified gear there is the opportunity
to acquire masks each global event has
commendations associated with it some of
these commendations will reward you with
unique masks check through your dosia
for the requirements
how do we get the most out of a global
event there are certainly faster more
efficient methods of farming for GE
credits but I strongly advise that you
try to vary activities as much as
possible or you're very quickly burn out
if not during the event then slightly
after and given that this is meant to be
every weekend for the month of March you
need to keep yourself motivated I'm
serious when I say this in each previous
global event i farmed every piece
available repeating the same mission
over and over for four to five days it's
brain numbing and after the event was
finished I really needed a break from
the game fortunately for me the next
global event was a fair amount of time
away but over this next month you won't
have the time in between here are some
options that allow for some fast GE
credits while still providing a little
bit of variation but again I recommend
mixing things up take advantage of the
global event but don't burn yourself out
hv TS don't rush straight into these see
the leaderboard section these are a
quick way of gaining a ton of credits
and can be used to increase your ranking
lights own bosses varied and quick to
complete Lexington this is the fastest
challenging mission to complete
even without the group or activity
modifier the ability to complete this
mission in 10 minutes or less makes it
one of the go-to s for global events
clear sky if you have a well coordinated
group you can complete this in around
five minutes and for a change of pace
the dark zone offers a bit of variation
you don't have to worry about extracting
just run around and kill named enemies
for the GE credits
when the global event has ended players
will be rewarded with caches along with
gear peace caches players can also be
rewarded with vanity items depending on
the player's position on the leaderboard
the amount of caches and vanity items
can vary between 1 and 3 these caches
can be found at the rewards vendor and
the base of operations your position on
the leaderboard is determined by the
maximum GE credits you have earned in
one hour of continuous gameplay a method
that is worked for myself is a mainly
solo player to keep myself in tier 3 on
the leaderboard is to complete a
legendary mission immediately jumping
into the weekly HV TS and a couple of
the higher daily HV TS and then finish
it off with some quick light zone
farming
personally I don't agree with the way
that global events have been initiated
as with any RPG if you offer your player
base the option to farm an in-game item
faster and more efficiently and then add
a timer to it naturally all hardcore and
even casual core players will take full
advantage of this ensuring that they
gain the maximum out of these events
don't get me wrong I'm not against
global events being replayed to help out
the players that weren't able to take
advantage of the first round of global
events just that global events in
general could have been better thought
over from the start essentially they've
introduced a really cool way of mixing
up the day-to-day activities but have
then added a hell of a lot of pressure
and grinding into the mix overshadowing
the modifiers and events in general but
regardless they're here and what's most
important to those of you who have come
to the game a little later on is to take
full advantage and level out the playing
field we don't know what's coming next
but for now I can say for certain that
these GE events are the best way for you
to gain classified pieces with or
without the upcoming drop rate increases
at this stage the data mined information
states that the global events are
planned for the following dates but
please note this hasn't come from an
official source and is subject to change
anyway hopefully this has provided some
clarity for some of you let me know if
you have any further questions about the
global events below and I'll see you in
the next video Cheers
[Music]